welcome to this video playing eight
miles high from cover star okay forget
the name in there let's check no oops
ukraine and I am sand GM in the text but
here's this I am and yeah sometimes they
don't update their title Bishop to b6
that's an uncommon way to play somewhat
strange looks um a little bit misplaced
on d6 maybe it was a mouse slip you
wanted to play Bishop e7 I don't know
yeah ninety-seven would be funny c5 and
black resigns ok here I get in efore and
this really looks weird
dad looks like a semi Slav wear black
has played Bishop d6 without any
particular reason ok so night is 70
maybe just develop let's not spend huge
time on that yeah but if I if now I
think a half night g5 which looks quite
problematic yeah and if Blackie cannot
go 'if I've or this didn't really help
them that much ok um yeah many good
ideas d 5 and the d5 this Knight e5 pawn
to e5 is of course a possibility
and it's nice for wide in any case
really but let's push e5 question is
should i play a 4 to prevent b5 not
clear maybe black will play c5 so the
support of a 5 is probably coming in
handy so that c5 can be answered with
defiant very conveniently yeah again I
can answer that will not be 6 is out of
the question as well so a 4 is probably
useful movie let's see young c5 there's
d5 that's all nice and good um still how
do I develop here Bishop here does not
really have any great squares
nitey for Bishop g5 might be an idea
maybe not frc 5c 5 d 5 that's not not
totally clear aged voice also
interesting yeah let's play it shop and
light takes knight takes Bishop takes
Queen g4 is a very very very dangerous
compensation nice taking it without any
big thought now black is in big trouble
I mean maybe maybe he had to take it
because the alternatives are also bad
but just grabbing it like that hmm okay
let's see 94 yeah maybe 90 attending 96
Queen to F forum Chim it's probably
probably a little bit better than
peeling queen of three
that was one threat okay so 96 I guess
this is at least good for wide question
is how good is it probably this is
better to just retreat you like has no
no decent move anyway and now I just
play e6 next door or bishop d to cover
only one so that 96 becomes very
substantial yeah bishop d to wear that
sets in fact the easiest way to continue
and now i have 95 or 96 which is also
terrible rack em all keep it simple just
wind material
damn I don't know taking h4 like
instantly can surprise me
yeah I'm just winning material now
keeping it simple as mentioned 97 98 I
still have an attack it's not like I'm
giving up on my attacking ambition cm I
can go e 6 as well but now come on it
just take this can play c5 but i have f
3 at least if everything else fails yea
or D 5 D 5 is also possible d5 Knight
takes rook takes takes on a 665 well
it's also also quite good but ok let's
play it like that just block the block
this long diagonal ya know i can go nite
c7 as well boy or six sixes no taking on
f6 actually for Queen c7 it's in even
easier for Quincy 70
yeah I only I was a little bit slow
black resign but it's just too too bad
this position yeah I don't know what he
did there but this wasn't really really
a good opening Bishop d6 already is
rather strange because I mean it does
not belong there simply no I'm
threatening to grab the pawn and
whatever black players it's not really
fitting together this was obviously nice
for wide and I mean this blunders a
piece and after this I just play here
and well ultimately the best move is
this which just gives the main line with
the temple down I guess this is probably
a mouse slip I mean no decent player
would play the move I think okay so what
happened in the game we had this doll
that was very very normal looking he
five wasn't possible due to nigeria vs
and black is exploding so this and now I
wasn't sure but II five is definitely
keeping an edge rookie one to support
e5a for to prevent be five or this looks
logical yeah I know age for I think this
is an interesting move it threatens h5
h6 and yeah if he takes it we saw what
happened here why just has a tremendous
position with nitey 46 coming and while
he cannot cancel I mean maybe you should
and give up the exchange but white is
just almost winning here and here this
is a comp wants to play rookie for the
rookie for is very nice actually
this is even more forceful than what I
played but very computer ish I know
where this is this is terrible retreats
and it takes f is even stronger okay are
taking on f6 and then Bishop t2 is even
stronger but this is also plus 11 so
yeah I guess plus 11 s is sufficient f3
takes and this is plus 24 probably only
takes some moments to get it to a mate
okay I hope you enjoyed this blitz game
thanks for watching